hey youtubers is Charlie dr. doom is
Iron Man as well as a couple other
characters so what's going on I'm going
to explain infamous Iron Man number one
in how they're kind of splitting aspects
of the Iron Man character across the
Marvel Universe so right now it just
seems like everybody is borrowing stuff
for Tony Stark
so spider-man has kind of taken over his
role in the Marvel Universe is the
wealthy industrialist who funds the
Avengers and I was like a really giant
cool building has all the cool toys the
riri Williams character is taking the
name Iron Heart but she's taking over
the invincible Iron Man comic so
ostensibly riri Williams is officially
taking the Iron Man mantle even though
she's being called iron heart but she's
going to be wearing the red armor so
Tony Stark picked her to kind of fill in
for him while he was gone but on the
other side of the fence here you have
the infamous Iron Man Doctor Doom
basically taking the mantle of Tony
Stark of his own accord without Tony
Stark's permission that's why one of the
most fun moments of this comic here is
Doctor Doom opening Tony Stark's closet
so to speak opening his armory his most
private area in pillaging his toy box in
a very dr. doom type way if you remember
the classic Civil War like we have Civil
War too right now but the old Civil War
after that Norman Osborn kind of took
over the Marvel Universe for a little
while and pillaged Tony Stark's armor
and used it to become the iron patriot
so this kind of reminded me of that even
though there's been a lot of stuff
happening with the Doctor Doom character
since the end of Secret Wars that makes
it seem like he's turned over a new leaf
even though there's a lot of classic
Doctor Doom I know best I'm going to do
things my way kind of stuff going on
here so if you haven't been reading a
lot of dr. doom centric storylines
Secret Wars was just like very dr. doom
centric so just to explain the Doctor
Doom character a little bit he's one of
my favorite Marvel characters that I
don't always read a lot of but because
of Secret Wars he became one of the most
important characters in the Marvel
Universe for a little while so you kind
of have to imagine that dr. doom is a
mix of Tony Stark Doctor Strange in
Norman Osborn so you have someone who's
really evil and brilliant someone who's
a master
of the mystic arts in sort of the
wealthy industrialist playboy persona so
it seems like what they're trying to do
is make dr. doom cool again without
making him outright evil but he's still
very much the classic Doctor Doom
character like there was a teaser at the
end of the New Avengers title where
Doctor Doom is facing the new team
saying you all work for me now and it
seems really evil but really what's
happened is his Doctor Doom is carrying
up Tony Stark's cause trying to help the
world but doing it in a very Doctor Doom
type way which is kind of what he did
during Secret Wars so it's like a
slightly less evil version of Secret
Wars Doctor Doom very powerful like I
love the way they put him against Iron
Man earlier in the invincible Iron Man
title where he basically just starts
trolling Tony Stark saying that he needs
his help with something but he's very
confusing about it Tony Stark eventually
is just like dude why do you keep
bothering me what is it that you want
from me and you never get a really good
answer but for all of his faults Tony
Stark uses his toys his intellect to try
and help the world so it seems like
that's what Doctor Doom is trying to do
too but as you can see he does not ask
for permission he takes because that's
what Doctor Doom does so they built sort
of this Iron Man style team around him
you have the AI
Tony Stark which is like supposed to
fully be his consciousness so you really
do have Tony Stark as like the new
Jarvis but then you have a Mara who's
kind of like his Pepper Potts albeit a
slightly more scientific spin on Pepper
Potts like she's not really his
assistant and then you have the rest of
the Marvel Universe like Ben Grimm here
who's going to be pounding the out
of him so even though it might seem like
Doctor Doom is Iron Man it's really just
dr. doom in an Iron Man costume doing
Ironman things in a very dr. doom type
way so while it seems like he might be
reformed because if you if you haven't
read Secret Wars Doctor Doom gained the
powers of the beyonders became the most
powerful person in the Marvel Universe
for a little while it totally went to
his head did not go well things fell
apart so that's probably what's going to
happen again eventually eventually
doctor dooms hubris always brings him
down that's what I love about Doc
they can make him look like vincent
cassell make him seem so much cooler
have a really awesome love interest
update his armor make him seem really
awesome but he himself is usually the
person to bring it all crumbling down
which is funny because that's also kind
of an Iron Man thing too Tony Stark is
his own worst enemy to the other big
twist remember Doctor Doom is very Magic
based character one foot in the realm of
science one foot in the realm of magic
is that it seems like his mother is
still alive and speaking to someone off
of the page so this is like the really
like the big magical part of the
storyline you have the more traditional
tech based Iron Man storyline stuff
happening but they haven't revealed what
the magical side of this infamous Iron
Man comic is going to be so whereas
earlier this year right after Secret
Wars they did international man of
mystery Iron Man they're kind of doing
the same thing with Doctor Doom now but
you guys let me know like what do you
think about vincent cassell dr. doom
international iron man of mystery
I think the pitch is really interesting
it just depends on how much these
storylines pay off or if they know where
they're going but you can kind of see
how they're rebooting the dr. doom
character trying to make him a little
more complex a little more sympathetic
they've almost infused a little bit of
Loki's playfulness into him that wasn't
there before like before he was just
really quiet and grumbled all the time
right now it seems like he walks around
with almost like a wry smile like he has
a secret that nobody else knows about
but what's going to happen is because we
still don't know what happened to Tony
Stark I'll do a video for riri Williams
taking the mantle next week after
invincible Iron Man number one drops
that's when we're going to see her take
the armor so hopefully they'll explain
what happened to Tony Stark at the end
of Civil War even though we still have
two more issues of Civil War to get yay
for comic book delays but because I've
been doing a lot more comic book centric
videos what I'm going to do is I'm going
to do a video for mini Batman vs. mini
Superman next week sometime
they introduced the new John Kent
Superboy to Damian Wayne so I'll explain
what's going on with that but it's just
like the greatest pitch ever I saw this
panel and I just thought why is this not
a TV show where is this TV show so mini
Batman vs. mini Superman sometime next
week be sure to subscribe to get that
this is
one of the most fun titles that I read
in the last week in just to clarify - I
just posted a video about the New
Avengers title spider-man made a
reference to Godspeed a flash character
because it's Mark way you know Mark Waid
longtime flash writer and a lot of
people seem to think that he was making
fun of DC Comics I was a little confused
by that reaction comic book writers will
reference stuff between Marvel and DC
every once in a while but for the most
part everybody's friends like Mark Waid
still loves the flash so he's not going
to try and say something hurtful about a
DC comic book but if you were confused
he was just making an offhanded
reference you know tongue-in-cheek
reference to a flash thing in the
avengers title so I'll post a link to
that at the end of this new Walking Dead
posting later tonight while you guys
wait for that you can click here to
learn about Mark Waid winking at the
flash in that Avengers title and you can
click here for my Doctor Strange review
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight there are two types of beings in
the universe